today i'm going to talk about what an
average work week looks like
in the life of a strategy consultant
welcome to another coffee break here on
my channel firm learning
my name is heinrich and on this channel
i want to help you to become successful
in the first
years of your career i worked as
strategy consultant for the consulting
firm mckinsey for about six years
and as you can imagine i did lots of
projects throughout that time
today i'm talking about how a typical
work week looked like and i have to say
that this
is a work week before the current health
situation so it reflects our typical
work week looked like
up until about early this year and
hopefully how it will look like
soon again so to walk you through a
typical work week i will now look down
here on my screen where i prepare the
schedule for you a work schedule for you
how this week looks like
let's start with monday monday is travel
day usually you will
fly in from your office location to the
client on monday
when exactly the flight goes depends a
bit on the flight schedule but also your
team preferences i had studies i had
project where i needed to take a six am
flight in the morning on monday that of
course is quite brutal
and can lead to you needing to wake up
at 4 00 am every monday i would say
average is getting a flight around 7 7
30 but then still this might require you
to stand up quiet early based on where
you live
then next once you are at the client it
is quite common to do something like a
check in and a check out every day with
your team
so here your team lead will come
together with the whole team sometimes
all together sometimes with everybody
individually and then talk to him what
his priorities are
for the day and then also at the
checkout at the end of the day
what the associates still have on their
plate
also to help them prioritize if he
realizes that maybe one guy really has
lots of stuff to do which maybe isn't
even required on that specific evening
then you will often have a weekly
client check-in so you will sit together
with your main client with your main
contact person
you will look into the whole work week
with them set the priorities for the
week and just the line and do a quick
check-in with them afterwards if you
have some time you will meet for
lunch so if the client has a nice
canteen you will often sit together
there with your team and just have some
lunch
and then after that frequently you will
sit together in interviews with clients
so these can be all kinds of interview
situations based on the type of projects
that you do
for instance maybe a finance guy from
the client sent you some data end of
last week and now you want to sit with
them
go over the data with them and ask some
clarifying questions that you might have
then you have a bit of spare time where
you sit in the team
room to get some work done until the
checkout then after the checkout if it's
a bit of a more slow
day then often you can then jointly with
the team drive to your hotel and you
might have a nice dinner
in the hotel restaurant and then after
dinner you go to your room and get some
work done from your hotel room and here
now in this example day you would be
done at 10 am with all your emails with
everything this is then where you can
really shut down your laptop and being
completely
finished at 10 pm is probably one of the
better
days 10 p.m we would have considered a
good day if you're completely done and
finished on that day and can really now
watch a movie or do something completely
it's after 10 p.m then for the rest of
the week you will often already have
some things
locked into your calendar for instance
the daily check-ins and check-outs this
is something that you will usually do
every single day and then on thursday
and on friday you might do the checkout
a bit earlier
on thursday to enable the team then to
fly out back to their office location
and on friday to enable the team to get
out into the weekend maybe slightly
earlier when exactly the check-in is so
when you are in the team room this often
deviates a bit
team by team so usually what i've
experienced is that around nine ish you
do the check-in but then people already
come into the team room around
8 to 8 30 to already get some first work
done and prepare the day a bit next you
might also have some internal calls
already scheduled so one thing that you
will usually have
once or twice every week is something
called a team problem solving where you
sit together with the whole team
often also one of the partners is flying
in joining you for the day
sometimes also only by telephone and
where you then discuss your progress
with the partner you discuss some
challenges that you are facing some
things where you need his input on and
try to solve certain problems that the
client might be facing another thing
that you will frequently do our
so-called internal expert calls
you will frequently look for experts in
your own consulting organization so
these are often more senior consultants
that have already worked on a specific
topic several times in the past and then
you talk to them
and you try to get their input on what
their best practice is what they believe
for your client should solve certain
problems then you will also have some
other pre-scheduled client meetings so
frequently you have a weekly draw fix
with the whole client team where you sit
together with the whole team discussing
the progress
and then often every second a week or so
you have the steering committee also
called the steer co
and this is usually the most important
meeting for you
in the week because this is where you
present your project
progress to your project sponsor on the
client side
and this is often a board member at
least one board member present
sometimes even the whole board or
several board members present
and this is then really the peak of the
whole work week
the key deliverable where you sit
together with the clients and you show
them what your results
are at this point in time now this being
clear then on tuesday you come into the
team room you have the check and you
conduct the joe fix for the jofix you
might have prepared a document
last monday night and then after the
dropfix maybe you just meet with another
person in the client organization to
just discuss some data
or some other questions that you might
have then you have the team problem
solving and here usually in such a week
you will focus
on the steer code document so focus on
the document that you will present to
this dirco on thursday
and then frequently now the partner will
have some suggestions some things he
asks you to implement in the document
and then he will ask you for a new
meeting on wednesday afternoon to
discuss the things that you are now
asked to do on the steering dock then
afterwards what we at least that
mckinsey always try to do is something
called sports
tuesday where you try just to block some
time for the whole team to do some
sports
and often also we did some group
activities you of course what you do
depends a bit also in your location what
the possibilities are so what we did for
instance was renting a soccer place
where we were playing some soccer as a
team or doing some crossfit with a
trainer or just some team
running just whatever the team fancied
and then after day like that everybody
would just go to his room frequently and
then just have dinner for himself on the
hotel room
and then just some last work that
everybody was doing for himself next
wednesday the same drill you get into
the team room you do your
check-in and then you might meet with
your key project lead from the client
side because often then the clients have
a project lead as well for the project
that you're working on and often in the
steering committees you want actually
the client
to present the documents to not make it
a consulting presentation
but rather presentation that is really
owned by the client as well
this of course requires that you align
the whole presentation with the client
and here you often run into situations
where actually you as a team would like
to put it in a certain way
but for whatever reason the client wants
to have things done a bit differently so
then you sit together with him you
discuss and then you do some changes on
the document
then you have the internal expert call
and then have some time to get some more
work done
before you talk to your partner about
the document and how unfortunately what
frequently happens is that maybe you as
a team you believe that document is
just perfect that you're completely done
but then the partner looks at it and now
he tells you that he has a completely
different opinion that actually wants to
do it the completely different way
and now you're really facing the
situation that you actually need to send
out the document
on that evening so for the meeting next
day but now you suddenly realize that
shoot you really have
lots of stuff to do what you also maybe
have seen that maybe on tuesday and
wednesday there wasn't enough time to
have a proper lunch people might have
just done a quick working lunch or even
skipped lunch entirely just to get the
work done so here is way because now you
realize that you have all the stuff to
do you just do a very quick dinner
in the team room maybe you order some
pizza and then the whole team
sits together in a crunch to really
finish now this theogo dog based on all
the inputs that you got both from your
partner
but also from the client in the morning
and now this can then easily take you up
until 1am
at night or sometimes even later so this
doesn't happen every day but these days
exist and unfortunately at least from my
experience they exist a bit more often
than you might have hoped for
and then next day even though you're
already stressed and didn't have a lot
of sleep
at least i often try to prioritize
sports so for me it was important to
always have at least two units of sports
during the work week so what i would
often try then just put in a little run
at least
in the morning independent of how long i
worked last night okay that was just my
commitment to keep me healthy but then
later we would go into the team room
get some last work done check in then
the steering committee took place and
here than often other partners fly in
the board members fly in and for me it
was always an atmosphere a bit like
sitting in an exam
right so you did all this study and then
the big meeting is
and then hopefully it went really way
far better maybe even then you hope for
and then everybody is happy and now that
just imagine that this is what happened
here as well
then you maybe sit together have lunch
the partner is there as well you can
talk a bit with them then you maybe have
another client discussion
then some more work then check out and
then you call it a day
it was a good successful work week
because the steer core went well
everybody will be happy
and then you travel out you fly out when
exactly you fly out
also often a bit depends just on the
habits of the team but of course also
your flight connections so i'd say you
have a flyout around
five or six this would be rather early
if you fly out after eight
this would be rather late so something
in between is what we usually had and
often frequently you just book a flight
you have it on standby because you have
flex tariffs so you can all the time
reschedule your flight sometimes even
after the flight has already departed so
you will often just log into flight but
then if there for whatever reason you
need to take a later one then you just
call your travel team you reschedule it
and then just take it later on then
thursday evening at home usually there's
not that much
stuff that you still do usually you then
after you arrive maybe you just write
some emails but then can call it a day
and then on friday you either work from
your home office or from the actual
office here the culture might differ a
bit in between the different mbb firms
what is expected at least at mckinsey
was always completely fine to pretty
much always work from the home office on
fridays if this is what you wanted to do
the only exception might have been if
your project lead came from the same
office where you are from then he might
ask you also to come in to sit with him
on the friday in the office then friday
often was a little bit slower you did
some work but then often you also had
some time to do admin tasks or
participate in any other office
activities so this can be grabbing a
coffee with some other colleagues some
other fun activities in the office or
often just doing your expenses on a
friday then again usually between five
to six we had the checkout on friday and
then often you were able really to leave
the office at 6 00 pm
and then call it a day and then start
into the weekend now regarding the
weekend this was something i
really enjoyed in considering especially
if you compare it to investment banking
and this is that at least at mckinsey
there was a very strong culture that the
weekend
is free you're really not expected to do
any work on the weekend at all there
might be some specific
instances where there's really a hard
business need but this is really
required and then yes you will be asked
to work on the weekend and this is also
expected from you but this to me
in my six years really only happened a
couple of times most of the times i was
really completely free and didn't do
anything what some people do like to do
is that then on sunday evening they take
some time to prepare
with the week but this was something
most cases i rather did
in the taxi monday morning or maybe even
in the plane so this
isn't really required if you don't want
to do that so that's it guys this is a
typical work week so probably just also
to put this a bit in perspective
this is not one of the lighter reeks but
this is also not one of the hardest
weeks that you can face right this is
probably something in between
and usually the weeks where you have
sphere cores so the steel core weeks are
a bit
tougher because you're into lots of
pressure of getting the document out and
then often there are all these last
minute changes and inputs
so in this context i would consider it a
representative week in mbb consulting
hope that was clear if you have any
questions on that please leave me a
comment below in the comment section
i'm very happy to engage in a
conversation with all of you about what
i discussed today if you took
any value out of this video at all
please hit the like button for the
youtube algorithm and also subscribe to
this channel
and turn on the notification bell to
stay up to date on my content
if you want to see even more from me
also follow me on my instagram my handle
is
firm learning and i also have a mailing
list where i share
even more content with you you can find
a sign up link to the mailing list
in the video description below thank you
for watching i very much
appreciate your time my name is heinrich
from firm learning i release new videos
every saturday so i would love to see
you again here on this channel next
saturday and
until then have a good weekend cheers
guys